hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the key math skill of calculating
a percentage you might ask why am i
doing math in biology well it actually
turns out that biology and other types
of science like chemistry and physics
involve huge amounts of math and
calculating a percentage is one of them
now how do you calculate the percentage
well you divide the number of parts by
the total and then you multiply by 100
for example if in a biology problem
you're told that 200 people in a
population of 800 have the allele for
blue eyes what is that percentage well
the number of parts 200 divided by the
number of the total which is 800 this
equals 0.25 times 100 equals twenty-five
percent so 25% of this population has
the allele for blue eyes you can also
use your understanding of how to
calculate a percentage to work backwards
if given the percentage for example in a
class of thirty ten percent get the flu
how many is this well here you're given
the percentage you're given the total
and you're being asked how many of the
parts so how many people get the flu in
this class and this is how you do that
ten percent we're working backwards / a
hundred equals point 10 and so now we've
got this proportion here the parts
divided by the total so multiplied by
the total and you get three so here
three students
get the flu in this class because three
is ten percent of 30 you can also use
your understanding of how to calculate a
percentage to do some more difficult
problems involving something like ppm
ppm is parts per million so it's a unit
of concentration so for example if
you're told that the level of dissolved
sulfates and a polluted lake is 5,000
ppm what percent is this well if it's
5,000 parts per million that is written
like this 5,000 over a million we can
cancel three zeros and we're left with 5
divided by a thousand which is equal to
0 point five percent so that is how you
calculate a percent in various
applications of biology that's it for
today thanks for watching